okay okay guys well welcome back welcome
back it's your boy psycho [ __ ] battle
was mad if you just got it in now what
we're doing is were smuggling this [ __ ]
over here is this child trafficking um
you know no one really knows but she is
part of the fireflies gang and the
fireflies are gonna give a [ __ ] tarragon
second a chef tom oh gods to do this
okay so uh we're gonna do this [ __ ]
sorry sir sorry he'd ain't like [ __ ]
away from the move oh [ __ ] okay so let's
do this [ __ ] oh god I got forgot that
I had to [ __ ] to everything okay oh
god oh [ __ ] gifting up a big strong man
Hannah now there's a lot up there's a
lot of weirdos out there [ __ ] sorry i
forgot i threw everything as well who's
waiting for us at the drug law she said
there's some fireflies
the way from another city
you're almost be important what is the
deal with you some bigwigs daughter or
something shut the [ __ ] out something
like that yeah something like that
something like that no nose actually
that shows his plan we should get Emma
Jessa Jessa Rana yeah yeah yeah betches
yeah yeah yeah Oh what's going on here
let's got on here hold up it's a patrol
of a good [ __ ] four trials thank God
come on you [ __ ] hilarious you stick
his head up and I don't have to
developers coated in lat like a raccoon
went up and over the [ __ ] forehead I
know why that kind of [ __ ] is hilarious
oh man you know just like juvenile [ __ ]
like that like did nothing like sing
like a grown strong man be bit piling
[ __ ] it um what do you call that uh
actually I was like racket oh yeah she's
pretty amazing Jake okay
all right let's stay that's that Davis
opens a shed spider-sense co says Claire
ok
huh Oh [ __ ] a spider senses you fall
right no [ __ ] turn around underneath
that Tessa that's one hot [ __ ] out like
that can I make new civilization with
her me know and I man that's right here
has pissed like a [ __ ] like what Mike
impossible I'll see well oh cuz if you
felt like I love ceiling like a pair of
stars look like a fan and blue petals
get away and to make this worth your
while ya suckers deck I did this game
I'd sarcastic even as a straight man I'd
sang a stack what's ETA couple minutes I
thought we were just gonna hold them up
or something yeah yeah that's why you
that's why he cut off his attendant on
this in the leg advice
o positive she's hiv-positive a bust-up
that's [ __ ] up Marlene citizen Shay
Santa's up that is right bet he'll we
smuggler they gave us a bog girl I'm not
infected no this is life this reader
says you have dr. Shockley's house
aren't you changing her tampon yes Wow
shut up toxic shock syndrome that's the
6 30 weeks old change the Tampa two day
so you stop bullshitting it's like
everybody's I swear three weeks of Tampa
why would she set you up viscosity
change them uh no maybe buy it I am
buying that [ __ ] that's disgusting why
would anyone use it same damn off their
weeks so we gotta go bet shoes rod rod
it go whoa rashi y la ana [ __ ] fine
ah shut me [ __ ] and they've its secrets
[ __ ] I'll just [ __ ] around in
[ __ ] [ __ ] see y'all later
[ __ ] see y'all later god damn it
they're everywhere
ha cubes they're everywhere oh [ __ ]
stay back you better check yourself
before you wreck yourself should I say
ya betch Joel hey guys gonna [ __ ] get
us myself a bottle no they're bottle
here
waiting from the changes flashlight
got it in ya got my slipper as a weasel
slippery as a weasel go ahead ya betch
so far so good
yep so far so good so leper as a ways
off shut
I hear him up ahead Ayhan tell betch
our chef they're not [ __ ] sales
aren't they hold up go go
ah what's on the move over
go go they see us
come on
I can't tell if you can see me or not
I guess they can't I guess he can't
and I am slippery as a fire
that's how you don't worry big strong
man doing all the work once again I'm
used to it easily I don't get depressed
anymore it's just my life now okay
hotshot thank you sir thank you if
there's anything I learned is that we
gotta go through this [ __ ] fast
thanks spider this lady let's go around
okay you're in here with us see if you
can distract yeah I know you that [ __ ]
so you better go check it out ah [ __ ]
come on tanner tanner
Shh
this guy's gonna shoot me
except bucket I have to run [ __ ] got
away [ __ ] you want to get shot oh [ __ ]
my dick hole but back in dec hole it
hurts okay okay I'm down here i'm down
here i'm down here oh that was messy
that was an essay things and not go to
plan I'm pressing ok Bruce and where's
that [ __ ] show oh she gave me a little
up straight didn't she hello a treat for
daddy thank you i'll bet you got that
see trying to push me at the [ __ ] you
own a [ __ ] lying about a [ __ ] man
oh that's right stay close stay close
bet you at least we're out of the rain
another an alright that's your shook
like we can squeeze the rear right good
[ __ ] here I don't want to miss anything
okay I guess there's nothing I can I
[ __ ] I got more soldiers
report back to secular life I don't
think they see
[ __ ] later that's nice okay this fire
this or anything here nothing [ __ ]
here come on give me something what is
this yeah the [ __ ] is here yeah no no
we're not safe bets take a moment do you
think we're [ __ ] safe you can go the
same should [ __ ] smack your [ __ ]
face to knock your if I can't take that
who you think you're safe I can't that
don't thank you very much can I get back
to the main show ok let's say here let's
say yeah I guess we're gonna I'm gonna
make a mole people let's go yes up
through here through this pie I think we
can make it through here why I can make
it shut ok all right wow that's the end
of this episode I help y'all happy
[ __ ] thanks for watching
all right there go look what was the
plan let's say that we deliver you to
the fireflies what been Marlene's she
said that they have their own little
quarantine zone with doctors they're
still trying to find a cure yeah we've
heard that before on tests and then
whatever happened to me is the key to
finding a vaccine oh Jesus that's what
she said oh I'm sure she did hey [ __ ]
you man I didn't ask for this me neither
Tess what the hell are we doing here
what if it's true good question I can't
tell what if Joel and we've come this
far let's just finish it do I need to
remind you what is out there well we get
the guns that we track down
kicks out for Harambee